[Music]
hi there
i'm farmer brad and i'm gonna talk about
chicken rental packages that i offer we
offer two or four hens for three or six
months
then at the end of the rental period you
have the option to
buy out and keep everything so what i
provide is
the coupe the hens the feeder
the water and some feed to start with
the goal with the chicken rental package
is that on day one
of the rental you get fresh eggs
in your backyard now i source the hens
either from our farm
or from a nearby farm so that they are
just starting to lay
so this coupe here is five feet by eight
feet and uh
this door you open up and that is where
you access
the feed and the water
and over here is where the nest boxes
are and that's where
you get your eggs i designed this coop
so that
majority of taking care of the chickens
can be done
from standing upright so there
is a release
for the door on the other side and you
end up pulling this cable
and then that will keep the door open
this is large enough
coupe that if you don't have a fenced in
backyard
you can just let the chickens be in
there
and then i can also add wheels to this
so it's easier to move around on your
backyard
now there are some additional fees such
as the
chicken replacement fee and the
mileage uh delivery fee so there's free
delivery
uh one way within 50 miles of greens
fork
and then beyond that it is uh
there's a surcharge per mile
also this year i'm going to be offering
up
a senior citizen bantam chicken rental
package
and uh kovit has hit a senior citizens
the hardest and sometimes you just need
that companionship
now the bantams are smaller hens so they
lay smaller eggs
but they take up less space so
when you go to the website you'll be
able to see the pricing for those
in order to get the uh
ball rolling there is a hundred dollar
down payment
so that way if i don't have a coupe on
hand
then that's enough up front cash that i
can start building one
the phantom
rental packages will be smaller
coupes and it will be a little bit more
affordable
so um check out
for the latest prices and details on
farmerbred.com forward slash
rentals thanks and have a great day